hoy vamos a hablar un poco de las
pruebas de fondo porque el objetivo
puede ayudar a ver ham en hombres y alem
un mejor tour entre las damas
conquistaron la edición del maratón de
sevilla de este año como le fue a umar a
la delegación latinoamericana que estuvo
presente en el evento fue un maratón
rapidísimo y les fue muy bien hubo
resultados muy interesantes por ejemplo
la peruana gladys tejeda quedó novena
fue la única que logró meterse entre
kenianas y de tío pues en ese 'top ten'
de la prueba con un récord suramericano
de 225
57 supera el récord suramericano de su
compatriota inés melchor y la argentina
florencia borelli logra una marca de 226
54 que se convierte en la tercera mejor
de la historia para américa latina para
suramérica perdón hay dos uruguayos
edwin cuesta y zamora logran la marca
mínima para los juegos para el
campeonato mundial de oregón y la otra
cosa interesante es lo hecho por héctor
garibay y el boliviano que logró una
marca de 20 90 4 la mejor marca técnica
de la historia en cualquier prueba del
atletismo para el bolivia